ras-le-bol de ces touristes sérieusement
barrez-vous ailleurs tendent à ses seins
c'est bon maintenant signé brice mezzo
alors brice n'était pas le seul
j en ai eu plein de messages comme ça
alors pour expliquer aux autres il y a
une semaine à peu près une semaine en
tout cas moi j'ai sorti une vidéo qui
parle du hellfest du hellfest 2010 est
où j'ai retranscrit avec mon pote mick
et on a fait les trois jours du hellfest
et j retranscrit un peu l'ambiance du
hellfest l'ambiance générale quelques
mois j'ai perçu j'ai montré le lieu ce
qui se passait c'est la toute première
fois que j'allais au hellfest
je connaissais pas autant les festivals
j'en ai fait des concerts après que tant
elle fait se connaissaient pas et j'ai
trouvé ça génial et j'ai retranscrit ça
en vidéo une vidéo qui doivent après 16
minutes d'ailleurs via le lien là ainsi
si vous voulez y avoir et j'ai eu une
chiée excusez moi du terme et une chips
commentaires haineux qu'est ce que tu
fous là
c'est quoi ces hipster qu'est-ce qu'il
faut que la dégager vous n'avez pas
votre place
j'ai été surpris pourquoi alors pour
plusieurs raisons la première c'est que
j'ai passé un festival extraordinaire
j'ai rencontré des gens gentils des gens
qui faisait attention aux autres
quitteront ils bousculent et s'excuser
des gens cool j'ai vu les coûts avec
plein de personnes que je connaissais
pas et tous des gens bien intentionnés
et il y avait une super ambiance et là
je me retrouve avec une bande de bikers
du métal
désolé les gars ça va probablement
déclencher les foudres et vous allez
mettre encore une tonne de commentaires
en dessous mais je fais tout expliqué et
je vais vous dire pourquoi je suis pas
d'accord avec vous une tonne et une
chiée parce qu'il n'ya pas de terme
excusez moi s'il ya certaines idées qui
sont quand même une vraie des vraies
idées de fermeture et puis de la
bouillie mental c'est dommage ces
tonnages [ __ ] il est bien ce festival
alors c'était parce qu'il y avait avant
je le connaissais pas donc je peux pas
on n'est peut-être pas dans un festival
un peu plus un décès sur qu'affectionne
la plus soixante mille personnes jour le
quota d'euros le côté underground
le côté indépendant il est plus trop là
mais bon il ya plusieurs années là pour
tout le monde en tout cas c'est ce que
je croyais jusqu'à il ya très peu de
temps alors je vous en dirai pas ce que
parce que brice est pas le seul à penser
ça il ya des gens bienveillants il ya
des gens bienveillants ya des gens qui
sont pas d'accord avec moi que tu le 10
mai mais qui sont bienveillants et c'est
cool quoi et il y en ad'autres ballon
ils sont ils ont trop pourri montage
robin ça c'est une question de point de
vue un jeu c'est pas grave j'ai pas dit
que j'étais le champion du montage peu
importe alors attends tu atteindras
cheveux ont trouvé un autre parce que
bon le beauf est bon mais y'en a qui a
priori critique le festival plus
qu'autre chose
j'ai fait quelques petites erreurs dans
ma vidéo je vais je vais aussi m'ont
expliqué je vous détailler sa en
plusieurs points mais je voudrais vous
vouliez quelques autres commentaires
franchement et ne pas ce que ça vous
fait de bien le pourquoi cette vidéo des
commentaires haineux denters il y en a
un je suis pas la première vidéo sur
youtube
il y en a plein j'ai l'habitude des voix
fou des fois ça me fait marrer c'est
rare que ça m'énerve mais là ça m'énerve
parce que ça va à l'encontre même de ce
que j'ai ressenti de ce que d'autres
personnes ont ressenti parce que je suis
pas le seul à dénoncer ces commentaires
assez c'est à gerber tu vas au hellfest
du film et attractions vont aux concerts
mec je vais t'expliquer dans quelques
instants comment j'ai fabriqué la vidéo
quelle vidéo de merde on dirait un
parisien pourri qui va à disney et cela
donne
de l'autre viiip c'est lamentable
paraître viiip je me la joue pas du tout
vip aucun droit pour la musique du court
reportage inutile on ne voit aucun
concert beau ouais mais ce n'était pas
le but et puis un coup j'ai pas le droit
de filmer les concerts j'en ai mis des
petits bouts à droite à gauche j'ai mis
des extraits qui sortait un peu du
contexte mais j'ai pas le droit de
filmer les groupes g pas l'autorisation
j'ai pas une accréditation presse et
j'ai encore moins le droit de mettre la
musique
là par contre c'est youtube qui va
m'arrêter parce que si j'ai pas les
droits pour mettre la musique il joue au
risque de me faire blacklister
problématique pour il y en a plein de
gens comme ça qui sont assez assez
critique je vous laisserai faire un
petit tour
voilà il y a il y à un moment soit en
profitent de ce festival haut en se
jetant dans les cercles juste
l'attribution et d'une bonne ambiance
bon enfant soit on se contente de têtes
d'affiché ont fait des montages vidéo a
de sous pour faire 30 minutes
j'ai pas prévu le nombre de vues qui
allait faire cette vidéo je pensais même
que l'heure n'est pas en faire des
masses mais bon là je aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs je tiens à vous remercier
tous parce que à l'heure d'aujourd'hui
on est à peu près à 48 mille vu en 6 5 6
jours donc je suis super content merci
en tout cas ce furent appréciées parce
que je t'ai a précisé la plupart des
personnes qui critiquent et qui sont
négatifs
later du métal son reste la minorité qui
parle la majorité silencieuse elle ne
critique pas et n'est pas négative en
tout cas parce que généralement ce
toujours les gens qui sont pas contents
qu'ils le disent ce qu'ils aiment bien
voilà ne le disent pas le ffs se meurt
depuis plusieurs années bordel ça c'est
dit qu'il le met ces losers on nous paie
ultra vomit parce qu'ils se sont couchés
tard ben ouais on est un petit peu loin
et est un nom c'est un peu galère mais
bon peu importe donc voilà je vous passe
un peu détails je vous invite à aller
voir les commentaires si ça vous
intéresse parce que il y en a une chiée
alors je vais développer cette vidéo en
trois points le premier point
premier point qui me paraissait un peu
débile je n'avais pas envie de passer
par là mais a priori faut passer par là
je vais répondre aux gens qui
considèrent que moi et mon pote mick et
qui font des photos souvenir qu'on avait
fait une soirée qu'on n'avait pas qu'on
n'a pas la légitimité avec là on nous a
même reproché d'ailleurs d'avoir vu des
billets d'être venu alors que d'autres
personnes qui seraient plus métal que
nous et qui ne les ont pas eu bon donc
je leur répondre à tout ça sur un
premier point sur le deuxième point je
vais répondre par rapport aux
imprécisions et erreurs que j'ai faites
ce qui irait dans cette vidéo
aujourd'hui fondamentalement désolé je
vais donc essayer de les corriger et de
vous expliquer le pourquoi du comment
puis sur un troisième fois je vais
rajouter un petit poids par rapport aux
gens qui m'ont demandé quelle était la
musique que j'ai utilisée pour faire ma
vidéo alors en commande sud avec le
premier point déjà on dit pourquoi toi
tu allais place il ya des potes à moi
qui aurai plus légitimité à les avoir
alors là on va très rapidement répondre
il y à une billetterie
c'est de la vente libre le premier
arrivé premier servi il n'y a pas
d'ordre de préférence
on n'a pas en train de faire on n'est
pas temps de regarder ton pour pedigree
1 voir si tu as plus de mérite que notre
apporta place tu viens tu l'achètes tu
la payes tu la payes pas tant pis pour
toi il ya des gens qui l'ont vu
quinze jours avant et j'ai même de
copines qui apparaît sur la vidéo kg ou
la veille du festival qui ont eu deux
pass 3 jours donc à un moment quand on
veut on peut ça existe désolé pour vos
amis je suis pour rien donc c'est pas la
peine de me le reprocher le point second
on me dit souvent c'est quoi ces c'est
quoi ces histoires d'hommes puisque
excusez moi au début de la vidéo j'ai
séché il est mouillé ans que je le lave
et je suis désolé excusez moi et les
lecteurs du métal si je lave mes
vêtements je les prends pas nous
reprocher il a ses vêtements c'est
dégueulasse on les remet dégueulasse je
fais de la caricature mais vous en
faites encore plus que moi donc quelque
part je répondrais paraît normal j'ai un
t-shirt hipster marquer ils se rasent
note
arnott super heroes of the cool
alors ok on va prochainement d'accent
probablement senti choc que m'a offert
ma compagne bon ben j'ai mis sur un tee
shirt que j'ai pris dans mes vêtements
je ne savais pas qu'il fallait forcément
avoir un dress code la prochaine fois je
m'achèterai un t-shirt maiden bon s'il
veut se déguiser je le ferai ou alors
même mieux si ça vous dérange j'ai pensé
à un autre t-shirt qui serait super cool
je sois dans la collection andré rieu
khrouf ouais parce que j'ai un moment
j'étais dans l'équipe d'andré rieu donc
voilà ouais c'est quoi ce mec
la variété de la musique classique il a
rien à [ __ ] au festival cloud relayant
êtes lourd alors pourquoi est ce que moi
j'ai tout autant ma place que les autres
et puis pourquoi on n'a pas à juger qui
doit avoir sa place qui doit venir dans
ce festival pour ou bonne et simple
raison on est sur un très grand festival
qui accueille à peu près 60 mille
personnes par jour là les organisateurs
ont fait le choix de plusieurs scènes
avec chaque scène avec un style de
musique différents
on reste dans une grande famille métal
voilà vous la faire vous le savez bien
mieux que moi parce que je pense que
vous êtes en plus bien mieux informé que
moi de tout ça mais pourquoi est-ce que
je n'ai pas ma place puisque vous j'ai
tout autant de la place que vous
d'autant plus que je ne suis pas le
hipster du coin qui ne connaît rien à la
musique métal et qui ne s'intéressent
pas la musique en règle générale et je
n'aurais jamais voulu devoir en arriver
là devoir expliquer pourquoi j'ai tout
autour de la place que vous ça sauve
même plus que vous ben ça me paraît
ridicule mais je vais quand même à
passer par alors je vais vous montrer
deux trois trucs ça fait chier de
décrocher s'installer il ya pas
longtemps ça ce sont tous mes bad que
j'adresse que c'était un homme et un de
mes premiers métiers j'étais technicien
sont 1
elle était assistant studio d'ailleurs
j'ai participé à de nombreux
enregistrements notamment un album
complètement indépendant 1,37 à new york
j'adorais ce groupe l'enregistrement est
écoulé l'inquiétait super gentil si vous
voulez vérifier je suis crédité de
dallas aurélien g1 je vous passerai mon
nom de famille mais je suis crédité de
dents g
j'ai donc si vous voulez fait une
formation de musiciens qui passait un an
à travailler la musique le solfège sur
une formation plutôt jazz le jazz
c'était pas trop mon truc moi j'étais
plus rock'n'roll comme garçons pas
forcément métal mais rock'n'roll c'est
pas trop cool à la formation
et puis je ma porte de sortie c'était de
faire un truc qui me plaît c'est
vraiment le son qui travaillait dans le
sombre je me suis formé j'étais
assistant en studio pendant un an j'ai
fait pas mal de collabo mais cette super
l'indépendance donc les gens qui ont
décroché de les voir que les russes
mutilées ou en tout cas essayer ça tu
vois ce que je veux dire truc
indépendant janvier j'en ai chié j'en ai
fait une tonne et les albums que j'adore
y en a plein de voix il ya un moment
faut arrêter de critiquer gratuitement
on ne sait pas alors c'est moi mais pas
savoir parce que c'est pas marqué sur
mon front mais c'est le principe des
gens les gens il n'est pas écrit sur
leur feront leur pedigree et ils n'ont
pas plus de droits aux moins de droits
que toi parce que sur leurs fronts il va
marquer ce que j'ai fait ou j'étais
alors on va continuer puisque vous pour
passer par là alors qu'est ce qu'il a
fait ce bon vieil ouveillan
bon alors il n'a pas fait du rock les
futurs cadres alors il a fait une cape
town alors massive attack
c'était passera métal mais bon j'ai un
peu de culture musicale intense at elle
vous plaire sage effet jennyfer un ses
coûts le bourg qu'un drôle
gt gt road un roadie parce que il ya un
moment bien il faut bien faire des
cachets quand on est intermittent du
spectacle et qu'on vit dans le monde du
rock'n'roll
la bomba renault s'est pas non plus
métal mais bon je veux dire j'ai roulé
ma bosse a besoin de ça pour faire
plaisir j'ai faits réels 5 et j'ai fait
laurie rouge et enchaîner et ben ouais
faut bien gagner sa vie un moment les
gains mais dans un milieu qu'on aime un
milieu en losange
voilà alors des festivals indépendants
j'en ai fait lire à un festival ça tout
petit festoche j'ai fait plein de trucs
cool
ça c'était on a fait là c'était pas
trainer pour un groupe qui s'appelle
s'appelait subway qui n'existe plus
aujourd'hui
c'est un groupe aufeminin rock'n'roll il
y en avait fait entre 80 parties placebo
est passé mais ta peau mais bon on a
fait des trucs cool genre des festivals
j'en ai fait plein je sais que vous
trouvez pas ce qu a priori photo
justifié pour pouvoir gagner sa place
donc je vais le faire ça c'est franz
ferdinand de johnny hallyday ou ben
ouais kool shen à jennyfer on fout un
peu
alors les nuits de fourvière festival
voilà si tu veux subway avec qui je
tournais c'était mon rôle access là
pourront apprécier fait plein de trucs
jamais fait tellement que je les nuits
sonores animaux bozouls passant des
tremplins voila voila je n'ai fait le
plein du tremplin dont on s'en fout des
trucs donc j'étais pas que les liens
entre des groupes de rock'n'roll donc
des festivals j'en ai fait plein j'ai
fait plein de festoche j'ai fait les
nuits de fourvière où j'ai bossé pendant
un bon moment
je cherche ce truc quand même pour
illustrer parce que je veux pas non plus
qu'on prenne pour un blaireau voilà des
festivals indépendants des petits
festivals en effet le big jama ce qui
n'existe même plus un tout petit
festoche le festival festi val de marne
on a fait mais on en a fait tellement
carrefour du rock
sachez plus comment il s'appelait cesti
vanité super les nuits secrètes c'était
vachement bien par sony gay fest'of
sensations des stations radio dont j'en
ai des pages illustré mais qu' on a sa
place
donc ça ce sont mes matches donc je veux
te dire des festivals gens
et fait des concerts j'en ai fait en
tant que spectateur parce que quand tu
es passionné que des spectateurs
tu vas devant tu regardes tu es là où et
puis à un moment tu es un peu plus âgés
tata des cheveux blancs 1 voilà tu as
moins envie de foot dans la fosse est à
faire secouer de partout ça veut pas
dire que j'ai pas là ce côté apprécié la
musique ça c'est pana alors ensuite on
va continuer parce que forcément comme
j'ai été devant où j'étais derrière
j'étais backline heures j'ai accordé des
guitares j'ai changé j'ai accordé des
guitares échanger des corps pendant les
concerts quand denis batterie j'avais
plein de choses pour un toit donc donc
si tu veux je pense que d'un point de
vue purement artistiques concerts
univers du rock
je pense que j'ai ma place mais et or il
faut tout prouver tout justifie on va
continuer ça c'est ma mallette
quand je travaille dans ce pays voilà
alors avec moi alors
puisqu'il faut tout justifier expliquer
pourquoi on a sa place
ça c'est la set list quand je jouais
avec un groupe tribute à pink floyd
ailleurs parce qu'il peut le voir on
voit la date là et marquer olympia 19
juin 2005
ça fait il ya un petit moment
effectivement mais ça tombe bien prouvé
que j'étais là que je les fais j'avais
toute ma cette liste est bronze mais
câble la [ __ ] mon truc de subway avec
up toute ma check list
voilà donc si tu veux j'en ai fait des
concerts à jeumont maintenant il faut
tout montrer donc je montre tout mon
accordeur mon face frais pour nettoyer
la vente vous avez je montre tout à
regarder celui là il est collector
puisqu'on va pas niable support auquel
roll ça là tu vois rolling stones 2003
tu sais vous faire ramasser ça j'étais
redis pour le concert des rolling stones
au stade vélodrome
sur une de leur tournée et ça je les
ramasse et sur scène donc ça veut dire
que je pense que c'est keith richards de
cajou au dessus donc je suis peut-être
pas un métalleux dans l'apparence ou
peut-être passé pour vous mais [ __ ]
des concerts j'en ai fait d'accord ça
c'est pour accorder les batteries peut
me dire que je suis passé rock et ça les
confettis c'est didier wampas qui m'a
lancé des pétards dans mouse
alors que je travaillais avec subway il
m'a balancé ses gros pétard dj didier si
tu regarde la vidéo je te fais des gros
bisous et c'est grâce à lui qu'elle a
été un peu légèrement [ __ ] voilà
d'ailleurs alors les traces de brûlures
merci didier wampas
si tu veux si vous voulez vous voyez
tout le monde parce qu'a priori nasa os
x jusque je pense que ma place je les
jets j'ai fait énormément concert
vraiment festival j'ai travaillé d'un
monde du spectacle
je sais ce que c'est un festival qu'est
ce que j'ai voulu faire alors à ce
[ __ ] de festivals et nice je vais vous
expliquer j'y suis allé en tant que
spectateur parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
groupes que j'aime et il y en avait
encore plus que je connaissais pas et on
a beaucoup j'ai découvert parce que je
n'ai pas pu tout faire
je suis un grand fan d'aerosmith jeu le
divine d'une part j'aime bien mais ce
n'est pas trop ma tasse de thé
ça c'est pour le tête d'affiche j'ai vu
deux groupes que j'aimais bien il y
avait plein d'autres groupes sur plein
de petites scènes je suis à l'écouté il
y en a je connais c'est là que je
connaissais pas voilà c'est pas grave
qu'est ce qui s'est passé pendant tous
estivale alors j'y suis allé avec ça
j'ai tout filmé avec ce truc là avec mon
iphone 6 s la caméra j'ai pas emmener ma
caméra pro j'y suis allé effectivement
bains ont découverte avec mon téléphone
je ne suis pas je vais essayé de fumer
puis on verra un petit plus que ça dit
j'ai été estomaqué par la scénographie
par par parle partout ce qui a été créé
par l'équipe par tout ce qui été
reconstruit j'ai trouvé ça énorme
gigantesque jusqu'au consignes jusqu'aux
toilettes jusqu'à tout gelé film est un
entier j'ai voulu tout filmé et tout
gardé en mémoire là dedans
pour moi avoir des souvenirs pour
pouvoir le partager avec vous
alors bien évidemment j'étais pas tout
le temps h24 en train de filmer comme ça
j'ai filmé des boules des séquences que
j'ai coupé et gfa montage avec alors il
y avait effectivement un deux heures en
tout deux parties capté deux heures pour
trois jours de festival je ne pense pas
avoir passé tout mon temps à filmer
j'ai passé beaucoup plus de temps à
regarder des concerts et à discuter avec
des gens passer une heure assiette avec
des mecs que je connaissais pas qui ont
fait des festivals depuis des années des
heures des heures et des heures de
musique à se remplir à découvrir plutôt
qu'à filmer vous ce que vous regardez
c'est une vidéo qui dure cinq minutes et
vous vous dites sur une vidéo de sept
minutes l'autre connard distincts il a
passé tout son temps à filmer et il a et
regarder dégagez vous avez rien à [ __ ]
là mais les gars au on peut réfléchir
deux minutes on peut essayer de
construire un peu une idée là dessus de
se dire que c'est pas que ça
éventuellement si vous le pensez mais
discuter on n'y arrivait pas en jugeant
avec vos gros sabots en me disant dégage
tu as rien à [ __ ] là mais qu'est ce
que t'en sais si j'ai quelque chose à
[ __ ] là qu'est ce que t'en sais tu en
sais rien alors tu me dis joue
aujourd'hui tu va juger d'autres
personnes demain tu as une attitude
globale du jugement
effectivement on touche à ce qui est
probablement pour toi un côté côté un
peu spirituel
musique métal je suis fondamentalement
désolé mais la musique métal s'est
démocratisé depuis plus 20 ans et vient
au for interne chez vous c'est par
essence il n'ya pas d'arrivée j'ai
rencontré des mecs des anciens qui
étaient là mais des mecs en respect les
gens d'un respect pourquoi est ce qu'il
y a tous ces connards qui vient de
mettre de la merde en commentaire alors
je devrais pas m'énerver devrait pas
employer tous ces mots là je vais
attiser la haine mais je veux qu'on
réfléchisse deux minutes est ce que moi
j'ai ma place et est ce que quelqu'un
qui n'y connaît rien en métal et qui
vient ce festival n'a pas sa place
prenons les autres que toi qui n'y
connaît rien il arrive dans le festival
il regarde il fait une vidéo où j'ai pas
dit d'où peu importe il vient je pense
que ce qui vous dérange c'est l'aspect
physique c'est ce qui est dégagée c'est
à bouger la tête ça vous dérange ce qui
ressort sur la vidéo vous dérange
comment on en arrive à découvrir et à
aimer ce genre de musique
soit on en n'est pas quelqu'un qui vous
unit si votre père des amis un nom qui
vous voulez soit vous y arrivez de vous
même
il faut un début alors je suis pas un
expert en métal c'est que là j'y connais
pas grand chose mais j'ai découvert
plein de groupes et j'étais très heureux
de faire si je n'étais pas venu je
n'aurai pas découvert et pourquoi est-ce
que j'ai filmé que l'ambiance générale
parce que je n'ai pas les droits pour
filmer les groupes films et la musique
la retranscrire je n'ai pas d'accès
backstage pour aller interroger des
routes
d'ailleurs je dis que l'année prochaine
ce qui serait bien parce que oui je
compte revenir désolé les mecs
ce qui serait bien les prochains
d'ailleurs c'est d'aller interroger des
festivaliers pour tchatcher pour
discuter parce que ça c'est cool aussi à
consigner ses cd souvenir si les moments
de vie c'est du partage donc
excusez moi les gars vous vous risquez
de voir ma gueule alors ceux qui ont
remarqué qu'il me faudrait mettre une
petite bouffe qui viennent de la mettre
en face année prochaine je pense que ça
va être coquin mais il faut arrêter
cette haine
il faut arrêter faut s'ouvrir un peu le
monde peut se rendre compte que lens
reçoit ça ne suffit pas ou alors ya des
îles dans nord où il ya de l'autre soir
mais il faut voir les résultats et les
gens ils sont un peu voilà on s'en fout
pas son autre chose j'ai fait les
approximations dans la vidéo et j'en
suis fondamentalement désole un moment
je dis qu'il ya plus de 300 groupes
erreur grosse erreur n'a pas le soleil
qui cogne sur la tête allait bien t'as
bu
bon il ya un moment d'une connerie il y
avait 160 groupe a priori avait une à nu
de rente ou 159 groupe je suis désolé 6
le chiffre est pas tout à fait juste
encore mais normalement il ya une sortie
de secours 159 groupe est pas 300
parlement pour l'approximation
à un moment je dis effectivement nous
sommes le 16 juin 2016 et je les ai vus
au montage j'ai mis en gros 2017
je m'en suis rendu compte je les
corriger excusez-moi de l'erreur excusez
moi une fois de plus le soleil tu parles
tu parle vite bon bah j'ai pas un texte
écrit j'ai pas un prompteur j'ai pas
répéter c'est quelque chose de vivant je
suis sur place je suis en train
effectivement de me laisser porter par
le moment et je fais une erreur dans la
date
bon moi je voudrais pas c'est un peu ce
que je corrige le montage après il ya
deux choses qui a qui a officié que
quelques personnes et je peux le
comprendre c'est quand je dis je suis
aux colts
eliane notamment le toit est propre
alors ce n'est pas pour dire que les
festivaliers qui n'ont pas accès aux
côtés qui n'ont pas payé le cult auxerre
des shots dégueulasse ça veut juste dire
que vu le nombre de personnes je
rappelle soixante mille festivaliers par
jour
vu le nombre de toilettes
à un moment les équipes de nettoyage ne
peuvent pas tout nettoyé en fond en
comble c'est juste humainement
impossible donc c'est pas du tout une
critique envers les festivaliers qui
n'ont pas accès aux cales ce n'est pas
non plus une critique envers les équipes
de nettoyage qui je suppose
on fait un excellent travail je suis
juste en train de dire que quand tu es
ok tu as beaucoup moins non des camps
plus le genre on vend des concerts donc
il ya un vrai turn over dans le lieu il
ya des toiles qui sont un peu plus
propre
c'est tout ce que j'ai voulu dire donc
désolé pour l'approximation et pour le
fait mal fait comprendre mais j'ai voulu
dénigrer absolument personne alors autre
point on m'a demandé quelle musique j'ai
mis parce qu'effectivement dans la vidéo
je n'ai pas mis la liste des groupes
tout simplement parce que je paye un
service sur une plateforme payante qui
s'appelle épidémique sand qui me permet
d'avoir de la musique est d'avoir un
catalogue énorme pour
mes choix musicaux pour insérer sur mes
vidéos youtube au jeu ne crédite pas
merci on me demande je le fais j'ai mis
dans la description de la vidéo du
hellfest 2010 est pas celle ci mais la
vraie vidéo officielle celle où les
alors je m'attaque j'ai mis la liste des
groupes
la liste des morceaux afin que vous
puissiez après les rechercher si
toutefois sa vous intéresser excusez-moi
de m'énerver un genou pour reconnaître
que c'est pas dans ma volonté ou mon
tempérament de me mettre en colère quand
on ne fait d quand j'ai affaire à des
rites earth
mais là je pense que c'est quelque chose
de très particulier parce que je savais
que cette vidéo ne s'adresserait pas
tout de suite directement au public
youtube on allait forcément s'adresser à
des gens qui sont plus des festivaliers
des passionnés de musique
ils sont pas dans la la cible en juin
d'un grand guillemets dans la cible
youtube donc
je savais pas du tout combien de vue à
le faire cette vidéo jour d'aujourd'hui
je ne sais pas combien elle fera pas à
terme parce que c'est il ya pas de faim
mais combien elle sera à son sa pointe
maximale et qui on s'en fout c'est pas
ça le but c'est d'avoir partagé avec des
gens que ça intéressait donc je ne
savais pas tout ça je voulais juste
partager cette expérience je tiens à
remercier le festival hellfest d'une
pour l'orgueil et et hop et puis de 2
pour avoir partagé sur la page du
hellfest sur facebook et sur la page
d'accueil
la vidéo ça m'a fait extrêmement plaisir
n'hésitez pas obligé je ne doivent rien
donc c'est juste gentil suppose que en
tout cas l'initiative leur a plu je
suppose qu'ils nous auraient pas
partager donc merci beaucoup au hellfest
désolé d'avoir rager mais je pense qu'à
un moment il faut recadrer ce que comme
je vous le disais ce n'est pas une cible
de hunters classiques sont des gens je
pense des festivaliers somme toute assez
normaux mais les moments là il faut il
ouvrir une réflexion l'a su sortir un
peu de sa bulle et puis se rend compte
que ici vous voulez que le land glider
grande il y à des concerts dans des
cadres et des concerts des petites
salles j'en ai fait plein mais le
hellfest
quand le regard ouvre sur un site énorme
a fait venir des grands tête d'affiche
pour fédérer un public le plus large
et puis il ya notre plein de scènes pour
plaire à tout le monde il faut accepter
que les gens différents de soi et ne
leur dit pas ne venait pas l'année
prochaine vous n'avez pas votre place
vous n'êtes personne pour juger de ça ça
me paraît être un discours et les mythes
extrémistes métalleux je comprends pas
je ne comprends pas parce que tous les
gens que j'ai rencontrés étaient des
gens bienveillants et des gens avec une
ouverture d'esprit donc je ne comprends
pas ce discours de haine
et puis de toute façon je refuse de les
comprendre merci d'avoir regardé cette
vidéo jusqu'au bout si vous êtes arrivé
jusque là si vous êtes d'accord avec ce
que je viens de dire
mettez-moi pouces peu importe si vous
êtes d'accord mais tu es un pouce parce
que il faut le manifester c'est très
important
si vous n'êtes pas d'accord avec moi
mais tu es un pouce vers le bas et puis
on verra au final un sont les intégrer
tout le ceux qui ne le sont pas et puis
vous mettez en commentaire alors si vous
commentez s'il vous plaît faites moi
plaisir en y mignon on échantillons se
crache pas dessus
advenant est ce que je veux dire bon
allez merci et sans rancune